listen i would imagine a lot of people
want to be in business with you but
it has there been a project along the
way that you haven't been able to get
made for some reason and if you could
get the financing you would love to make
yes like six or seven or eight
which is the one that is like top of the
list like if someone gave you the
financing this is the one i would make
maya lord this is a film about you know
the only
um you know uh conquiscadore who did the
right thing do you have a script that's
like ready to go oh yeah oh yeah that's
all
all there
like i have actually like kind of
figured out you know i mean it's like
everything is about tax rebates these
days
and mexico doesn't have a tax rebate
and that's like kind of holding off that
project because you need the 25 30
percent
you know to make something affordable
i i've heard this from every filmmaker
in every studio um if if someone has
actually never seen any of your movies
what is the first one you want them
starting with
anonymous
is there a reason
that's just like and i think my best
movie
okay um what do you think it is you are
very good at destroying our planet
people love watching end of the world tv
shows end of the world movies what do
you think it is about the genre that
people love
keep like they keep coming back to it
i think it's like just uh seeing you
know our world destroyed is some sort of
uh
you know i mean when you look at the
bible for example that also ends with
like a big destruction you know i mean
this is like kind of
in us as as humans that we like to see
these kind of movies
and uh
and yeah that's like and i think that's
the there's something in the core of us
we kind of uh like to see our world
destroy when you are depicting what's
happening with the moon and the science
in the movie how much are you sort of
trying to make it as realistic as
possible but you also realize [ __ ] it
we're making a movie and we just have to
have fun
yeah but you have to always you know i
think you have to always uh
make it as
some sort of correct as you can i mean
scientifically correct as you can
because you cannot like just like throw
stuff on the screen
and nobody believes in it anymore so you
go like out of your way to make it like
kind of seem like
uh really happening
but it's a totally fantastical story i i
listen the vfx in this movie have to
look good or you're not going to believe
anything thankfully the vfx in this
movie look good um especially the stuff
inside the moon and i'm just curious
could you talk a little bit about what
were some of the shots that really you
struggled with inside the superstructure
well it was like kind of mainly actually
every shot with the
anomaly or like the
your swarm uh you know uh
that was like actually the hardest
because we had a
frame store uh doing everything outside
the moon and we've d-necked everything
inside the moon and we had to both have
them like develop
a look for this thing and they have had
totally a different you know uh kind of
predatory they call it always briatory
uh uh techniques you know and they don't
want to share them so you had to kind of
some sort of figure out a way
how to make this look the same that was
like tough
uh i i can't even imagine uh john
bradley is very good in this movie at
selling
the conspiracy and the levity he has to
do a lot what surprised you about
working with him because he's very good
in this
well first of all he's the nicest man on
earth
i mean i have never ever met anybody
that like accommodating and and and then
he is one of the best actors i mean it's
his
incredible
what he makes out of the material and
where he like adds a little joke and
he's he's really really a a very very
accomplished and so you know and uh
he's now like again in the next
david benihoff vice
tv show so it's like kind of his
is really really amazing
uh without getting into spoilers um the
ending of this movie postulates
somebody um built the moon uh and i'm
just curious did you always have that
answer or did you debate who it might be
like how do you know what i mean
well we always like kind of thought
that we like have to go um
then it has to be
you know somebody who knows what they're
doing right so it had to be a terribly
advanced
culture
and
which had like kind of one
terrible
thing happening to them
and they kind of
kind of built these moons and they
wanted to actually build many moons but
only one
escapes the destruction and that's
what's like always for me
the the story i wanted to tell the end
of the film has a character talking to
another character i'm not going to
reveal anything and the there's a line
of dialogue saying something and it's
sort of setting up what could be the
next movie when you write something like
that do you already have the answer or
do you like sort of putting yourself in
a corner and saying he's going to say
that and we're going to figure it out if
we make another
no we have like an idea what should be
the next part but that naturally belongs
ask me after the
opening two three weeks
if this will happen
yeah we spoke last time you mentioned
that at the beginning when you were
first uh coming up with this movie that
you thought of it as a trilogy and then
you were like i don't even know if i
want to make another one um are you more
inclined if it's a hit that you would
want to make another well you know it's
money it's like it's hard to kind of
find money for movies these days
it's uh when you when you're not like
inclined to do a marvel or dc comic uh
book movie because you i grew up in
germany uh we have not this culture
uh you know and uh
so so
it's it's hard to get any
money for a movie so if there is like a
possible
two and uh moonfall two and three
i'm i'm very much looking forward to
that because that's uh it was for
probably a higher budget and um and no
more covet
that was the worst
fingers crossed um listen i got to stop
there but i'm just going to say again
congrats on the movie and i really look
forward to talking to you further uh
this week at the screening okay